[Música]
oi meu nome é anne tenho dez anos e hoje
ele faz sobre racismo vários
preconceitos dos bolivianos em são paulo
andando com os meus pais no centro de
são paulo mas vezes na região do braço e
me deparei com pessoas que chamaram
muita atenção os aspecto triste
cabisbaixo são os bolivianos que vivem
entre nós mas como chegaram aqui o que
fazem aqui eles vieram da bolívia com
destino a são paulo através de uma rota
rodoviária com quase 2 mil quilômetros
quando chegou aqui eles tentam buscar
emprego nas oficinas de costura
mais uma triste realidade é que quando
pegar nas oficinas chegou a trabalhar
com uma carga horária excedendo a 15
horas de trabalho diárias que apenas uma
parte do cotidiano que eles enfrentam
quando deixou sua pátria mãe em busca de
território brasileiro
as mais urbanas também acabou sofrendo
com isso porque quando contato acesso de
trabalho elas não têm como cuidar de
seus filhos opinião de deixá los
as crianças também acabam sofrendo
preconceitos pois não sabem a nossa
cultura ea nossa língua como minha avó
selênio twitter que veio da europa até o
brasil em 1951 e sofreu mesmo
preconceito com o resultado de tantos
preconceitos acaba gerando um grande
protesto nas regiões
mas mesmo com tanto preconceito e
sofrimento
a cultura do ms forte mas como posso
ajudar podemos chamar a atenção através
das redes sociais criar blogs e chamar a
atenção das autoridades para cuidar
desse assunto social
obrigada
[Música]